dauerbewachung ein leben in angst
bedrohungen damit soll jetzt schluss
sein für ihn für bushido er wandert
jetzt aus mit der gesamten familie
verlässt er deutschland
ich bin zu hause ich bleibe auch zu
hause um wäre heute alle sachen aus
rubbeln da wird demnächst umziehen
familie fertig gepackte koffer mutter
vater sieben kinder ziehen bushidos
familie will weg aus berlin weg aus
deutschland und sich ein neues
ungestörtes leben aufbauen und ich hätte
mich dazu zwingt nun die sachen zu
behalten und wirklich nicht schon einmal
zu trennen weil ich so ein umzug ist
immer richtig gut dafür da richtig
auszumisten aber es fällt mir - es ist
ein neuanfang nach jahren der angst
deinem leben unter polizeischutz und
ständige öffentliche aufmerksamkeit
rückblick nach jahren der freund und
partnerschaft kennt sich gangster rapper
bushido 2017 von arafat abou chaker
jahre lang war der kleinbus nicht nur
sein manager sondern auch einer seiner
engsten vertrauten
bushido rappt wird zu einem der
erfolgreichsten künstler deutschland und
seine familie bauen ihr clan imperium
auf gemeinsam hätten sie millionen doch
dann der bruch bushido will raus aus dem
milieu sein leben ändern für die familie
exklusiv bei bild äußert sich der rapper
im oktober zu den gründen assad und dem
absacker klaren den rücken zu kehren an
dem tag an dem morgens auch dass das lka
und teilweise auch andere beamte dann
bei uns im kinderzimmer stand und unsere
kinder in ihrem kinderbett standen aber
auch für mich ein punkt wo ich gesagt
nein ich will das nicht mehr doch der
kleinbus lässt seinen schützling nicht
einfach ziehen erfordert millionen von
bushido doch der will nicht zahlen aus
freunden werden
der höhepunkt 2009 10 aus racheplan hat
und seine brüder einen säureanschlag auf
bushidos kinder und die entführung
seiner frau anna maria seitdem steht die
ganze familie unter polizeischutz kein
schritt unter bewachung kein freies
leben mehr eine schwere belastung auch
für die kinder unsere älteste tochter
hat war sehr verunsichert eine ganze
zeit auf grund weil sie die personen die
die die bedrohung darstellen persönlich
kennen das hat sie glaube ich tief
erschüttert und ich weiß nicht was das
für auswirkungen haben wird später aber
sie hat das bewusst wahrgenommen und war
bei radtouren ist nur noch neben mir
gefahren auch wenn die polizei bei und
zwar alle personenschützer die ich vom
lka kennengelernt habe durchgehend
sondern absolut super nette korrekte
typen und genau also mit denen ich noch
viel lieber zeit verbringe als mit
irgendwelchen typen die ich aus der
vergangenheit kenne und das muss man
sich mal vorstellen ein leben in sorge
um die ehefrau um die kinder um die
familie der rapper macht sich bis heute
schwere vorwürfe ich habe diese leute
ich habe dieses diese dieses diese
atmosphäre diese flair und diese
entourage und und diese kultur die habe
ich den das leben meiner kinder gebracht
abschließen können die fesche hieß auch
nach jahren nicht seit sommer 2020 läuft
am berliner landgericht der prozess
gegen arafat und drei seiner brüder
bushido ist zeuge und nebenkläger die
früheren partner und freunde sprechen
nur noch vor dem richter würdigen sich
keines blickes bis zur bushidos und anna
marias hochzeitstag vor wenigen wochen
als arafat diese gruselige video
nachricht anders glückliche ehepaar
richtet sich als euer trauzeuge wünsche
euch zum zehnjähriges jubiläum nur das
allerbeste und ich als ein ehemaliger
rosa bruder um die not will nur das
beste für euch und euren kindern was als
nette geste verpackt ist ist reine
boshaftigkeit die auch als versteckte
drohung gedeutet werden kann der
geplante säureangriff und die geplante
entführung wegen erst drei jahre zurück
ein leben in ruhe und frieden scheint
für die fesche schießt in deutschland
völlig unmöglich keinen schritt können
sie unbeobachtet gehen die bedrohung
sitzt ständig in ihrem nacken ihren
wunsch deutschland zu verlassen um ein
freies leben zu führen nun wollen
bushido und anna-maria ihn wahr werden
lassen der beginn für ein neues
friedliches und glückliches leben